this program is brought to you by Emory
University
you're standing here today in the
brand-new and we personalized
immunotherapy center cell processing
core so it's a state-of-the-art
pharmaceutical grade sterile suite which
allows us to manipulate human cells
outside of the body for an extended
period of time so we can put them
through boot camp to give them back to
people to treat serious disorders for
the the concept behind that their
personalized immunotherapy Center is the
idea that we can harvest a crop of your
own cells from blood or marrow whose job
in life is to fight infection but in in
this room using novel techniques we can
retrain those cells rather than fighting
infection use them to attenuate an
over-exuberant immune response such as
can be seen in really serious health
problems like Crohn's disease or other
complications arising from cancer care
these are really exciting times the use
of your own body's cells and your own
are best for Anu disorders as opposed to
somebody else because of immune
rejection issues and teaching hospitals
such as Emory are perfectly suited to
really develop that technology in a
manner that big pharma cannot do and
will not do and we're experts at this we
do in doing bone marrow transplants now
for more than a quarter century a memory
is a really big Center for that then
what we're doing here is sort of a six
degrees of separation from that we're
using not only bone marrow cells but
others and this facility is the first
key enabling infrastructure that will
allow us to move forward in a manner
that very many schools and teaching
hospitals can't do because they don't
have this the type of technology were
developing will be useful for autoimmune
diseases a low immune
eventually cancer and infectious disease
so but you can't do everything at the
same time you got to choose your your
battles and our rd day our first break
through the cell therapy study will be
specifically for pediatric Crohn's
disease so you may not know this but ten
percent of all Crohn's patients are kids
and you can be particularly severe are
up there fourth of them within two years
of the bowel resection the big deal and
in what we're doing here is a team
effort and there's sensational doctors
at the Children's Hospital of Atlanta
chewbacca gothis and amongst them who's
like a national international expert in
pediatric Crohn's disease so subra and I
have teamed up as well as a whole team
of investigators and scientists to push
forward and bring this innovative
technology to first help children with
crohn's disease unit latter from a
practical perspective we've now built an
outstanding team of scientists led by
dr. Ian kaplan who's the program manager
who's a laboratory scientist was
actually developing the SOPs or standard
operating procedures by which we define
how cells are collected how they're
handled how long or what are the what
are their characteristics before we give
him back and we need to develop all this
for the fda so in the short term once we
actually collect a few milliliters amero
required from a person let it be a child
or a grown-up it'll probably take a
roughly three weeks for us in this and
lab environment to produce a crop of
cells that are not genetically
engineered so we're not doing anything
to then they'll change their like
chromosomes but they're basically
activated using biological methods and
then we can give it back so it takes
about two to three weeks so that's why
we have to choose disorders where we
know the need is there but we have a
window of opportunity to
so this might not work as well for say
somebody who has a life-threatening
disorder that you need to do something
within 24 hours but since we're we can
see this coming long ahead this is the
type of ailment we're with the window
two to three weeks it takes rest
produced two cells and then to
administer so we're basically we feel
that treating up to a dozen kids could
be done within a year we don't do
anything to the children's that they're
going to receive it like a blood
transfusion they don't receive like
chemo or anything else it's like a blood
transfusion it's just that we're giving
you a very very large dose of extremely
potent cells that normally are quite
rare in your body but what we do here is
we grow a huge crop event so we give you
a very large dose of your own cells
whose job in life is to hose down the
immune response so they go in and
they'll home in to where the
inflammation is of the gut for Crohn's
and there they also their hose down the
inflammatory response and that's what
we've seen in mouse models of crowns so
they don't divide or anything else they
they're just we're just putting back a
large amount of soldiers and they're
just going there knocking down the bad
guys and once their job is done they
basically will over a period of weeks or
months vanish well from our standpoint
the epic center represented a unique
opportunity family healthcare one it's a
tremendously promising area for
scientific development for new therapies
for some very difficult diseases human
disease that need new therapies to be
effective and frankly self cell-based
therapy and the related biological
therapies around that truly looks
promising second we always want to be
close to new therapy development in
emory healthcare and this enabled us to
associate with a unique laboratory that
would further differentiate us in the
overall health care market it's Emery's
point of differentiation to always have
unique in the latest science translating
into patient care and this is just one
example that will forded us that
opportunity with this type of therapy
and science and therapy opportunity
under development it's hard to say
exactly where it's going to take us so
you really want it in close partnership
with adult patient care systems
pediatric patient care systems and as
well as obviously it's integral to a lot
of what's going on in the School of
Medicine overall research efforts so
that kind of multidisciplinary approach
on the part of all those organizations I
think only further enhances the
potential around the epic Center and
what it can achieve well I think for
Emery and I'll speak for emory
healthcare I think these types of
programs that really show this kind of
promise are critical to our future again
it continues to differentiate us in the
market but if you look at look at the
first clinical trial they're about to
take on with respect to Crohn's disease
I mean cell therapy and the related
biological agents that that can
potentially produce to modify the immune
systems response when you talk about all
the autoimmune diseases is critically
important going forward that's a new
frontier that frankly a lot of other
therapies have not been very effective
at dealing with in a sustained way this
really has tremendous promise for
serving a lot of people and their health
care needs this is very powerful
technology and it can only be done in a
very few places and when Jacques came
and told me about his vision for this it
struck me that this was a time where
every needed to become involved in this
technology it's a wonderful platform for
the our ability to treat extremely
complicated diseases I mean patients
that have lupus patients that have
inflammatory bowel disease patients with
HIV patients with cancer in theory all
of these are approachable through this
sort of platform technology you have to
have a critical mass of science and
thinkers and in in windship Cancer
Institute in our vaccine center at Shaw
aflac we have enormous resources there
that this Center will help us bring
together in ways that they've never been
brought together before that's the power
or what it does is it opens the door to
new therapies and the therapies that
we're teaching our residents and medical
students today will be supplanted by
many of the therapies that we're working
out here in this instant and in other
places around the country so what we're
doing is opening the door to this latter
half of the 21st century a little bit
earlier for our students and residents
than for others the preceding program is
copyrighted by Emory University